ambiance était à la confiance
aujourd'hui devant les écoles il faut
dire que juste après le confinement les
protocoles tâtonner mais aujourd'hui
après plusieurs mois de recul
tout semble bien mise en place par
exemple les parents d'élèves attendent à
l'extérieur de l'établissement ils ne
peuvent plus entrer on leur apporte les
enfants pour éviter la circulation du
virus alors peut-on parler de rentrée
presque normal comme l'a dit le premier
ministre jean castex je n'irai pas
jusque là car des règles viennent un peu
compliqué cette rentrée par exemple le
port du masque est obligatoire pour tous
les élèves à partir de 11 ans donc au
collège port du masque obligatoire dans
les salles de classe également en salle
de récréation et port du masque
obligatoire également pour les
enseignants les professeurs les maîtres
d'école à partir de la maternelle les
autres gestes à appliquer sont les
gestes barrières par exemple les enfants
sont invités à se désinfecter les mains
dès l'entrée à l'école et puis
évidemment la distanciation social tout
cela est expliqué dans l'établissement
je vous propose d'écouter certains
parents concernant leur réaction face à
cette rentrée j'ai trouvé que c'était
plutôt bien organisé que les gestes
barrières étaient respectées et voilà la
direction de l'école c'est plutôt bien
préparés à cette rentrée assez
particulière on avait le droit de
rentrer dans l'école mais les enfants
devaient se laver les mains avant de
pénétrer effectivement il fallait porter
des masques pour les parents voilà
c'était plutôt bien cadré bien organisée
après il est compliqué pour des enfants
d'aller au delà je veux dire les
protocoles trop strict ne pourront pas
être appliquée pour nous ça a été ça a
été ça dans le sens où l'on connaissait
déjà les consignes a vu que c'était
diffusé à la télé un peu partout un peu
partout mais c'est un call l'école
ils nous ont pas rappeler les consignes
à nous mais je pense qu aux enfants ils
ont dû le faire pour remonter leurs
attaques les consignes là ils ont quand
même eu plus de moi couronner la chose
et l'expérience en fête de l'avent de
l'avant vacances donc là je pense que ça
devrait aller
alors que se passera-t-il en cas de
contamination d'un élève ou d'un
professeur et bien des fermetures de
classes ciblées pourront être réalisés
et dans ce cas le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent a expliqué
qu'un congé parental pourrait être
accordé pour garder les enfants qui
n'auraient plus classe voilà ce qu'on
peut retenir de cette rentrée pas comme
les autres sachant que le protocole
pourra être adapté au fil de l'épidémie